he represents radical change in
Argentina a farride presedent for a
country in the middle of an economic
crisis Kier M says he's like a lion with
a strength to jumpstart Argentina's
economy we are Advocates of freedom and
that implies a clear alignment in terms
of geopolitics and our geopolitics align
with the United States and Israel that's
our International policy we are not
going to align ourselves with communists
M was born in 1970 and decided to study
economics after seeing Argentina's
constant financial
troubles he became known for his
eccentric personality and a style his
strong media presence turned him into a
favorite character among young people
and he was elected to congress in
2021 M has four dogs named after liberal
economists they're clones of his former
dog Conan who died in 2017
author Juan Gonzalez wrote one of the
first books on Javier
M mle believes he can talk to his dead
dog he believes God destined him to be
in politics and that his cloned dogs are
his children I think he's had a rough
life he was beaten had no friends he's
unstable and I'm not sure he's the best
person for an unstable
country even though m is not Jewish the
first trip he made after winning the
election was to the United States to
visit the tomb of araba in Brooklyn
people in Argentina are filled with
uncertainty about what Javier M will be
able to do while in office he has
promised to radically change Argentina's
economy and while many hope he'll be
able to stabilize the economy others
fear the impact that his reforms will
bring about mle will write a new chapter
in Argentina's history many hope he will
succeed where everybody else
failed Teresa aljas
buenos make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer